I think of all the stories that we've
investigated so far,
all the fundamental and myths of
creation that we've investigated so far.
The two that we're going to talk about
in detail today are probably the two
stories that have had more impact on the
course of world history than any other
two.
I'm going to talk in some detail today
about the story of creation laid out in
genesis,
and also the story of the Buddha's
enlightenment.
Both stories are also characterized by a
kind of depth that's virtually limitless
and I think in some ways that the topics
we're going to discuss today are the
most enlightening of all the many ideas
that we've traveled through so far in
this series.
So we're going to be concentrating on an
analysis of this Schema.
Again,
the idea of being here,
of course,
that the world of experience,
which is the world that mythology is
attempting to describe,
has these fundamental constituent
elements.
One associated with chaos or nature or
the unknown,
one associated with culture or the great
farther or the predictable and another
associated with the architect will son
the individual who's the offspring of
the interplay of these two fundamental
forces.
Now given that part of the purpose of
this series is to elucidate the causes
of war and motivation for war attention
paid to the dualistic nature of the
individual is of paramount importance.
So we could say that just as nature has
its terrible side and just this culture
has its terrible side,
so the individual has his or her
terrible side and the depth of that
capacity say for atrocity and
vengefulness is just as deep as the
depth of terror that the unknown itself
holds.
I think this is so called,
uh,
difficult fact for normal individuals to
grass given that we're highly motivated
to view ourselves as if not precisely
good,
at least as relatively harmless.
But the evidence that as individuals we
are relatively harmless,
is very,
very thin indeed.
And I don't think it's possible to
understand the depth
of motivation for atrocity and social
conflict without coming to terms with
the capacity for evil.
That's characteristic of the individual.
Now,
both the story in genesis and the story
of the Buddha's enlightenment,
uh,
laid bare in many ways the nature of the
structure of individual eval and also
not only it's structured,
but it's motivation.
Why it is that people would turn more or
less voluntarily away from the good and
embrace what can only be described as
its polar opposite.
So in addition to making reference to
this structural Schema,
of course,
we're also going to be discussing,
it's the typical mode of interaction of
these elements of experience.
You may note for example,
that this diagram with which you're now
very familiar,
that the notion of order chaos and
reestablishment of order also parallels
the structure of the story in Genesis,
the creation myth where human beings are
created first and existed.
A paradise will state that that paradise
is disrupted.
That as the,
as a consequence of some,
some uh,
event,
uh,
virtually cosmic significance,
that as a consequence of that
disruption,
people are destined to live a profane
existence in constant wait for the next
state of,
of order.
So just as this is a fundamental
archetipal structure,
so that fundamental architectural
structure is,
constitutes the,
the basic grammar for the story in
genesis.
Now what we're going to do to begin with
is to do describe precisely how this
idea of paradise descent and the search
for paradise is illustrated symbolically
agenesis and exactly what those symbolic
representations mean.
The idea here being that the reason that
the authors of Genesis,
the multiple authors of Genesis six
extending over thousands and thousands
of years chose those symbols is not
because they were laboring to be obscure
or not because they were establishing a
pre empirical representation of reality.
I kind of,
cause I seem to scientific
representation,
but because these symbols have an
elusive or metaphorical richness than
enables a story,
although short to be characterized by an
almost infinite depth.
That's part of the reason.
The other part of the reason is that
when you say something profound,
you say it using the language,
the chorus language that you have access
to.
And if the story is almost unalterably
profound,
then the images in which is in shrouded
are almost in comprehensively complex.
Then it has to be that way.
Because if the target of the
investigation is reality itself,
something so complex that we cannot
conceptualize it fully,
then the language that we use to
represent that reality has to stretch us
to the limits of our ability to
understand.
And it is the case that historian
genesis say as much as the story of the
Buddha's enlightenment constitutes an
artistic endeavor on the part of the
human race to portray the nature of
human reality and to explain that
behavioral and philosophical
consequences of that reality,
that being a tall order,
perhaps we should forgive the multiple
authors for only being able to manage it
in a way that's essentially images stick
and dramatic rather than explicit,
logical,
philosophical,
and fully developed.
So the first thing I'd like to point out
to you is to,
is a statement made by Garcia Eliod,
which I think is one of the most
enlightening things I ever read.
Now the first thing that Ellia does is
describe the universality of flood
mythology,
but then he puts a twist on it.
So the idea behind flooding mythology is
something like this.
If societies deviate from an emergent,
unnecessarily emergent kind of morality,
a kind of reality that takes the
viewpoint of all the inhabitants of a
given society into account.
If it's society deviates from that
viewpoint sufficiently,
it dunes itself to annihilation.
That annihilation being represented
mythologies mythologically as the
flooding of the society by that pre
cosmotronic water sleep,
the primordial element or chaos.
So societies that are tyrannical doing
themselves to eradication by chaos,
a simple equation but made more
complicated by Ellie.
He's observation that more than one
factor plays a role in the establishment
of a tyranny.
On the one hand,
there's the straight degeneration of
cultural presuppositions in that if you
establish a state or a game,
which has particular rules because of
the environment is constantly
transforming itself.
The rules by necessity become out of
date.
So merely as a consequence of the
progression of time,
the presuppositions on which any state
or found them tend to become less and
less relevant to the current
environment.
Okay,
so there's this aging and senility
merely as a consequence of thermodynamic
processes.
But then Eliana also points out that
there's one additional factor which has
to be attributed not to society,
but to the individuals that make up that
society,
which is that the strictures and rules
on which society is founded,
Ken,
be constantly and carefully updated when
necessary,
if all the individuals that make up dot
society are perfectly willing to
confront exemplars of emergent chaos in
their own lives.
When those exemplars and merge,
which is to say that it's perfectly
reasonable to be guided in your
personality by the structures of your
state.
But if you face something unknown that
those rules cannot handle,
it's a moral necessity and obligation on
your part to face that emergent anomaly
forthrightly to souls,
it if you can,
and then to communicate the consequences
of your solution to the rest of the
members of your society.
Now with Elliot,
it points out is that the individual
who,
who removes him or herself from the
responsibility of confronting their own
and normally speeds the process by which
the state decays.
So the decay of the state and the
possibility for the emergence of chaos
is an interaction between the tendency
of the state to a archaism and senility
merely as a consequence of change and
the voluntarily,
the voluntary unwillingness of the
citizens that comprise that state to
face the unknown courageously when it
confronts them.
So Elliot,
it says the Deluge myth is almost
university disseminated.
It is documented in all the continents,
although very rarely in Africa,
probably because of the relative
shortage of water and on various
cultural levels.
A certain number of variates seem to be
the result of dissemination,
first from Mesopotamia and then from
India.
It is equally possible that one or
several dilute catastrophes gave rise to
fabulous narratives.
But it would be risky to explain.
So widespread of myth by phenomena of
which no geological traces have been
found.
The majority of the flood myths seem in
some sense to form part of the cosmic
rhythm.
The old world,
people by a fallen humanity is submerged
under the water and then sometime later
a new world emerges from the aquatic
chaos.
In a large number of variants,
the flood is the result of the sins or
ritual faults of human beings.
Sometimes it results simply from the
wish of a divine being to put an end to
mankind.
The chief causes light once therefore in
the sins of men and the decrepitude of
the world by the mere fact that it
exists.
That is that it lives in producers.
The cosmos gradually deteriorates and
ends up falling into decay.
This is the reason why it has to be
recreated.
In other words,
the flood realizes on a macrocosmic
scale,
what is symbolically effected during the
New Year Festival,
the end of the world,
and the end of a sinful humanity in
order to make a new creation possible.
So then the question might arise
logically enough.
What is it that would motivate an
individual to work to avoid a normally
when it emerges in his or her own life
and to risk and eventual flood even more
profoundly,
what would motivate an individual
perhaps to work for the antithesis of
order to work,
to promote the emergence of chaos?
Since we know that people are relatively
ambivalent in their moral stance,
is it possible that we can create a,
a compelling motivational story for the
desire of the individual as such,
to work against the emergence of the
good rather than for it.
So let's take a look at what genesis
says about the creation of experience.
So first of all,
remember we're taking a phenomenological
stance on this story,
which is to say that this story is not
an objective retelling of I've
materialistic emergence.
It's something more specifically
dramatic.
It describes the nature of human
experience.
Okay.
The nature of conscious human
experience.
And in fact the creation story in
genesis lays explicit stress on
individual consciousness,
literally as a precondition for being
itself.
Which is to say that underlying the
story of genesis is the notion that
without whatever consciousness is there
would be no segregated entities and
therefore no being so.
This is one manner in which genesis
attempts to put human beings at the
center of the cosmos,
so to speak,
which is the idea that the world
independently of consciousness,
whatever that world is absolutely needs
to be reflected by consciousness in
order to exist in any sense that
existence could reasonably be defined.
First chapter in the beginning,
God created the heaven and the earth and
the earth was without form and void and
darkness was on the face of the deep.
Now the idea that the earth was without
form and void takes us back to the
Mesopotamian creation myth and Marduk
and tie mat.
Because the word for void,
the Hebrew word for void,
his tail and Tam is a word derived from
ty Matt.
And the void,
the chaos that constitutes the unformed
condition of the cosmos prior to the
elaboration of being is assimilated to
the same category as tire mat,
which is this terrible,
unformed and frightening a priori
condition that has to be courageously
confronted in order to manifest itself
as being.
And the earth was without form and void
and darkness was on the face of the
deep.
So now you see another,
another interplay of opposites here
between matter and water,
the primordial elements.
So first of all,
it's heaven and earth and then it's
earth and water and,
and the height and the deep and the
spirit of God moved upon the face of the
waters.
So another opposite representation
between spirit and whatever it is that
the pre cosmotronic water or chaos
constitutes.
And God said,
let there be light and there was light
and God saw the light that it was good
and God divided the light from the
darkness and then a prototypical
division between light,
which is associated with illumination
and enlightenment and consciousness
because we're conscious during the day
and the sun and life that emerges nested
inside this initial opening lines of
this sentence,
uh,
northrop frye notes that there's
tremendous emphasis on the notion of s a
repetitive cycling of days and nights in
the opening sentences of genesis,
even though from a formal perspective,
this emphasis is paradoxical because the
notion of the day merges before the
creation of the sun and fry's point is
not that this is some careless gesture
on the part of the people who authored
genesis,
but more that it's an attempt to
emphasize the idea of a cyclical
relationship between consciousness and
light and darkness and chaos.
And,
and,
and to highlight the idea that it's
cyclical relationship is somehow
absolutely vital to being itself.
So genesis one five says,
and God called the light day and the
darkness he called night and the evening
in the morning where the first day fry's
says,
the central metaphor underlying
beginning is not really birth at all.
It has rather the moment of waking from
sleep.
When one world disappears,
a world of virtuality and potential and
another comes into actual beating.
This is still contained within a cycle.
We know that at the end of the day,
we shall return to the world of sleep
and,
and that's a notion that has a
metaphorical resonance because there's
the sleep that punctuates periods of
consciousness,
and then there's the great sleep at the
end end of life,
which is characterized by the complete
cessation of consciousness.
We knew that at the end of the day we
shall return to the world of sleep,
but in the meantime there's a sense of
self transcendence of a consciousness
getting up from an unreal into a real or
at least more real world,
but a sense of awakening into a greater
degree of reality is expressed by
hereclitis as a passing from a world
where everyone has his own logos into a
world where there's a carmen logos.
The experience that we all share.
Genesis presents the creation as a
sudden coming into being of a world
through articulate speech,
which is another aspect of logos.
Logos incorporates the idea of creative
exploration and then the formulation of
the consequences of that exploration and
verbally communicable categories,
right,
which give our,
give our aspects of our being there
defined boundaries and parameters and
enable us to establish a shared mode of
social being
through articulate speech,
conscious perception,
light and stability.
Something like this metaphor of
awakening.
Maybe the real reason for the emphasis
on days and such recurring phrases and
the evening in the morning where the
first day,
even before the day is we know it was
established with the creating of the
sun.
The most fundamental pair of conflicting
and sick likely interacting pairs of
opposites that is portrayed in genesis
is essentially the,
the pairing of chaos versus order.
Generative chaos versus generative order
and a poem expresses this idea extremely
well and very powerfully,
so I'm going to read it to sacred night
sweeps.
Having word she takes the glad the wind
some day and folding it rolls up.
It's gold carpet that had been spread
over an abysmal pit,
gone vision like as the external world
and man,
a homeless orphan has to face an author
helplessness naked alone.
The blackness of immeasurable space upon
himself.
He has to lean with mind,
abolished,
thought and fathered in the dim depths
of his soul.
He sinks for nothing comes from outside
to support or limit him all life and
brightness.
Semen,
ancient dream.
While in the substance of the night
unraveled alien.
He now perceives a fateful something
that is his by right?
Absolutely brilliant poetic statement.
I think laying out very nicely,
very richly that the fundamental nature
of the existential paradox that
constitutes human life pointing to a
very profound sense of futility in
theory,
but then beyond that to the notion that
in the depths of the unknown,
in the depths of the darkness and in the
depths of all that,
that's fundamentally unfakeable,
there are still lurks something that can
be discovered given sufficient courage,
another fundamental division portrayed
indirectly in genesis the word versus
chaos.
So what you have in genesis is an
absolutely stellar idea.
I think perhaps the most fundamental
contribution of archaic Jewish thinking
to Western and world civilization,
which is that although it is easier in
some ways to consider the actual matrix
of things,
their material substrate as the strata
from which they emerge,
it is equally reasonable and perhaps
more pragmatically useful to know that
things only exist because of the
interaction between the logos,
the word that characterizes
consciousness and whatever this matrix
is.
So in Jewish thought and then Christian
thought and of course in in thoughts of
that sort of echoed throughout the
world.
There's the idea that consciousness
associated with the transcendent
directly associated with the daddy is
actually the thing that in the
interaction with this matrix give re
gives rise to being genesis plays a
stress places stress on this notion of
the internal logos,
the individual consciousness and to very
complex ways.
It's first stance that it's the word of
God,
the logos of God that gives or that
gives ordered to chaos and makes being
emerged.
But then even more particularly it's
the,
it's the self conscious logos of
individual humans,
their capacity not just to see the world
as an object but also to see themselves
as an object that gives the world that
particular value slump that it has for
us.
Which is to say that not only are we in
a world where the subject and the object
are separated and,
and,
and therefore experience and suffer the
consequences of that separation.
But even more particularly,
we are the only creatures who are so
conscious that we can observe our self
as objects.
And the consequence of that is that
because we've extended our consciousness
to ourself,
we're capable of conceptualizing things
that other creatures cannot
conceptualize,
such as the infinite possibility that
lays manifested in the unknown,
but also the fact that as individuals
were subject to our finite limitations,
right,
that we can become diseased,
that we can become mentally ill on that
finally will die.
And so the idea here is that something
like the extension of logos to the
object to the subject has made human
existence finally problematic.
And Genesis refers to this as
essentially the heritable sin of Adam
because we're aware of our own
vulnerability as a genetic consequence
merely of being human.
There's a transformation in the nature
of experience that has essentially
cosmic significance.
Lout sue and the Dao de Jing makes a
comment on the formless chaos that
constitutes the matrix of things,
the origin of things in the following
manner.
He says there was something formless yet
to complete that existed before heaven
and earth without sound,
without substance.
This is the void or the chaos dependent
on nothing,
unchanging,
all pervading unfailing.
When we think of it as the mother of all
things under having the idea here being
that whatever experience is in the
absence of a delimited human
consciousness is something that's
outside the boundaries of time.
Because time is a temporary is a human
attribute and it's outside the
boundaries of spatial limitation because
only human beings with their delimited
and fixed size can attribute spatial
aspects to being itself.
So whatever it is is that exists without
us.
It's so comprehensive and so complete
and transcends temporal dimensions to
such a great degree that it can't be
conceptualized as being at all.
It's something that transcends being to
such a degree that it's not even
nameable but still exists as the mother
of all things under heaven.
Now,
genesis formerly associates the human
being with logos.
And this is a determinitive move in
human history,
just as the Mesopotamians first
hypothesized that their emperor was
equivalent to Marduk the force that
confronted timeout and carved her into
pieces and made the world.
And just as the Egyptians conceptualize
their pharaoh as the intermingling
between ocirus stability of the state
and horace,
the exploratory hero,
and then disseminated that identity down
the aristocratic levels closer and
closer to the individual individual.
So the ancient Hebrews said,
and God said,
let us make man in our image after our
likeness.
Now it could be said that the logical
derivation of that statement is that God
looks like human beings,
or conversely,
that God is an old man with a beard,
but it means something.
I think that's more sophisticated than
that,
which is that the central aspect that's
associated with this transcendent daddy,
the logos,
which is the thing that gives rise to
order as a consequence of his
confrontation with chaos,
is also the thing that centrally
characterizes human consciousness.
And so with that,
there's this transcendent notion that
inside each human being is a spark of
genuine divinity,
and it's the manifestation of that
divinity in human,
temporal and spatial parameters that
literally keeps the cosmos generating.
So God created man in his own image,
in the image of God created he,
him male and female,
created he them and let them have
dominion over the fish of the sea and
the fall of the air and over the cattle
and over all the earth and over every
creeping thing that creepeth upon the
earth.
Now the fundamentalist Christians read
this as an injunction,
right?
This is what human being should do,
dominate all other living things,
but it's more like a description,
which is that the consequence of the
embeddedness of this spark of divinity
in the individual is precisely what gave
rise to the human ability to dominate
the planet.
We just an ability that at least at the
moment,
seems fundamentally unparalleled with no
limit in sight.
So it's not an injunction so much as a
cold hearted description.
There's a very profound idea underlying
the necessity of the creation of the
individual human big.
There's a line of Archaic Jewish
speculation that runs something like
this.
Why is the creation of a limited subject
necessary?
If God's Omniscience and omnipotent and
omnipresent,
why would he bother creating anything
outside of himself?
And the line of speculation runs like
this.
The one thing that a being that is
complete in all regards,
even all hypothetical regards,
lax by necessity is limitation.
And as a consequence of that,
anything that's absolute is not complete
and can't be complete without
limitation.
And so there's an emergent idea in
genesis and most notions of the
emergence of human consciousness that
the absolute needs,
the reflection point of a delimited
being to actually spring into some kind
of defined actuality.
So that being itself becomes an an an
interplay between the necessarily
limitations of the finite and the
transcendent reality of the absolute.
And so being is something that emerges
because of the fact as another ancient
Jewish tradition has it gone in man or
in a sense twins mutually dependent on
one another for their defined being from
such a perspective being has the same
nature as a game.
When you're playing a game,
you have to play by rules,
which means that there are things that
you can do well playing the game with.
There are many,
many things you can't do,
and that the game could not exist
without the limitations.
Also predicated on the idea that the
imposition and Nietzsche and idea that
the imposition of limitations on a
structure actually gives rise to the
possibility diverse new forms,
which is also a very sophisticated way
of conceptualizing the world.
So from the perspective of Genesis,
the individual is the low cow of the
experiential drama,
and the fact that the individual is
limited is a necessary precondition for
being right.
Okay.